[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We've created a simple
Hello World app for Python
so you can quickly get a feel
for deploying an App Engine
standard app to
Google Cloud platform.
Before I started, I made sure
to install the Google Cloud
SDK and the App Engine
Python components locally.
In the Cloud console,
make a new GCP project
and create an App
Engine application.
Choose the region closest to
you, in my case, US East 1.
I'm going to do this
project in Python,
and a standard App Engine
instance works great.
First I locally clone the Hello
World Python app from GitHub.
Everything you need is in a
Python doc sample directory,
including this
minimal Python file
to handle the response
to the HTTP request.
The simple YAML
file included starts
the app, which you can
view on local host.
Start the app and then test
it by visiting localhost:8080
to see that it's working.
Hooray!
You have Hello, World.
Now you can leave the
development server running
and make changes that'll
be automatically detected.
The server will
reload automatically
after I make any code changes.
Let's change the text
in main.py and watch.
Good morning.
To deploy to App Engine,
run "gcloud app deploy."
It picks up the project
you created earlier
and will upload all the
relevant files to GCP.
Once that's finished,
you can check out
the app in your browser
with "gcloud app browse."
And now you're live
on appspot.com.
Congratulations!
That's it.
You've deployed your
first App Engine app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]